in the so-called blue wall of Tory
constituencies in Southern England such
as the lib Dem Target of Guilford it
seems the Boris Johnson drama is
damaging the party I'm a conservative
supporter but you know I wouldn't
support them at the Magnum guess when
there are policies alone it doesn't
matter whether he's there or not
you needed to go but you should have
gone quietly there's no confidence left
in the man whatsoever so
this could have ridden's the bad rubbish
I think I think it is
a Witch Hunt I think it's good that he's
resigned
though he'll probably come back to be
honest and after some spectacular
by-election victories the lib Dem leader
sir Ed Davey is hoping for another upset
in mid bedfordshire after the
resignation of Johnson Ally Nadine
dorries the sooner we can get rid of the
conservatives the better and there's a
chance here in mid bedfordshire in a
by-election where we can send a real
strong message to the conservatives that
we need that general election we need it
soon Rishi sunak now faces three
difficult by-elections and warnings of a
Tory Civil War after Mr Johnson and
another Ally Nigel Adams also quit
morning but cabinet loyalists dismissed
talk of Mr Johnson running for office
again and insists the PM did not block
peerages from as Doris and Mr Adams he
had successes many successes to his name
in including breaking the brexit in past
and including getting this country
vaccinated first but there was also
always a lot of drama that came with all
of that the world has moved on later the
Lord's committee that vets nominations
for peerages reveal that it turned down
eight people Mr Johnson recommended
the next ACT in the Johnson drama comes
as MPS on the Privileges committee meet
to conclude their report on the former
PM it's expected to judge that he did
light a parliament committee says it'll
then publish the report promptly a
former close Aid of Mr Johnson claims
the process has hounded his old boss out
of politics and that the MP chairing the
inquiry Harriet Harman is biased she was
Deputy leader of labor party for a long
time can you imagine any labor supporter
being happy if someone like William
Hayes shall we say uh had had the fate
of kirst armor in his hands when he was
caught drinking beer and having curry
with friends A Long Way from Home in the
middle of lockdown but on the evidence
of Voters reaction to the Johnson Saga
in Guildford it's left Mr sunac in a
hole John Craig Sky News